arriving in Wapping reading his final
copy of the news of the world the first
British paper he bought it snow former
owner Rupert Murdoch in town on what is
said to be a scheduled visit at stake
his billion pound deal to take control
of BSkyB still backing the papers former
editor at noni's international chief
executive Rebekah Brooks Mr Murdoch
maintains she still has his total
support he will find her successor Andy
Coulson the man in the editors chair
when much of the alleged phone hacking
was going on today on police bail mr.
Murdoch probably has to do about three
things as soon as he lands in the UK
today the first one is to make sure the
BSkyB deal is on track or back on track
and he needs to assess that he also
needs to effectively steady the ship he
needs to calm everything down and then
he needs to get some guys around him
that he really really trusts and find
out and there is no suggestion that this
is the case and find out that none of
his other titles here in the UK have
been involved in hacking questions to
today for Assistant Commissioner John
Yates of Scotland Yard speaking here in
2009 concluding the wars no need to
reopen the police investigation into
alleged phone hacking at the news of the
world no additional evidence has come to
light since this case has concluded I
therefore considered no further
investigation is required that he now
says was wrong making an unprecedented
apology it all the sunday telegraph I
didn't do a review had a new and then
what I know now all bets are off I would
never have reached this conclusion I am
accountable and it happened on my watch
and it's clear I could have done more
the Yates was asked to look back into
the original carrier and he took
precisely three hours to do so before
coming out saying there was nothing
significant that had changed his mind
about the original inquiry and the
significance of that was that use
international played great reliance on
the police statement they they came out
all guns blazing saying look even the
police say there's nothing to look at
here and so is the final editions of
what Wars Britain's biggest paper hit
the newsstands today the scandal that
brought it down is refusing to be put to
bed and use the world itself may now be
gone you can't reverse e that killed
lives on Katie stallard sky news